so where we left it was that we've got
ourselves now a fully connected network
so it makes no assumptions about the
size of the input the number of
parameters we're going to have it just
adapts itself depending on the size of
the input which for images you can
imagine makes quite a lot of sense they
change size quite a lot but in most
other ways it acts exactly like a normal
deep network we've talked about this
before in other videos like the deep
green one but the deeper you go into the
network the sort of higher level
information we have on what's going on
its objects and animals and things
rather than bits of fur and edges and
the shallower we are we have much less
idea but the shallower we are we also
have much higher spatial resolution
because we've got basically be input
image size because of these max pooling
layers mostly every time we down sample
what we're doing is we're taking a small
group of pixels and just choosing the
best of them the maximum and putting
that in the output and that just have
society image and hard it again and hard
it again and you can imagine it if
you've got an image of 256 by 256 we
might repeat this process for five six
times until we've got a very small
region it's done for a couple of reasons
one is that we want to be invariant to
where things are an image which means
that if the dogs over to the right we
still want to find it even if it's or
over to the left and so we what we don't
want it to be affected by that the other
the other issue quite frankly we don't
have enough videogram yet and we mu teen
lee fill up multiple graphics cards each
of which has developed gigabytes on it
depends on the situation you're looking
at this is only one dimension I've drawn
here but it's actually two dimensional
if you have the x and y dimensions
you're actually dividing the amount of
memory required for the next layer by
four and then by four again and then by
four again and so actually you save an
absolutely massive amount of ram by
spatially downsampling and without it
we'd be stuck with very small networks
indeed but we've got this problem that
yes we've worked out the cat so an image
or something like this but it's very
very small right it's only a few pixels
by a few pixels we've got a rough idea
there's something going on here maybe we
could just blip balloon it up like it
like a large linear up sampling and just
sort of go well that's roughly a cat but
it wouldn't be anything interesting so I
guess the interesting thing happened in
2014 when Jonathan long proposed
kind of solution to this which is
essentially an a smarter upsampling what
we do is we we essentially reverse this
process basically we have a sort of an
up sample here which will maybe double
the size and then we we look over here
and we bring in some of this interesting
information as well and then we up
sample again and we go alright so we can
this is now the same size as this so we
can bring in some of this information
and when I say bring in I mean literally
add these two these and we can have
convolutional layers here to learn that
mapping so we can take nothing from here
or everything from here it doesn't
really matter
and finally we up sample back to the
original size and we bring this in here
using a Sun now what we've actually done
is a kind of smart way of making this
bigger I mean Carly you've got to kind
of try and get your head around it but
these features are very sure what's in
the image but only roughly where it is
these features are much higher pixel
resolution they're much more sure in
some sense where things are but not
exactly what they are right so you could
imagine in an intuitive way we're saying
well this is a cat and down here we've
seen some text to refer let's combine
them together to outline exactly where
the cat is this is a kind of idea and
you can use this for all kinds of things
so people have used it for segmentation
or we call semantic segmentation which
is where you will label each pixel with
a class depending on what is in that
pixel traditional segmentation usually
meant backbone and foreground now
semantic segmentation means maybe
hundreds of classes so for instance in
the image on scene here it might be you
the table the computer the desk the
window yeah this kind of things and
there's a huge amount of different
applications for that kind of thing so
on a basic level you could imagine just
trying to find one object specifically
in a theme so just for people it's I
have a person or its background we don't
care what else or you could be training
this on something like image net with
lots and lots of classes or I mean
there's the MS cocoa data set for
example that has lots and lots of
classes and so you're trying to find it
airplanes and cars and things and people
do this on street scene segmentation as
well so you could say look given this
picture of a road where is the road
where is the pavement what's a building
where are the road signs and actually
analyze the entire scene which is
obviously really really quite powerful
the other thing is that you don't have
to segment the image instead of
segmenting it you can just try and find
objects you can say instead of just
outline
where an object is yes or no why don't
we try and draw a little heat map of
where we think it is and then we can
pinpoint objects so we can say where the
two pupils on a face or can we draw
around someone's face or their nose or
their forehead so that we can benefit a
model for that so Aaron was doing this
in his network where he was actually
predicting the 3d and positional
information of a face based just on a
picture and you were want to go with
that we've also been using it for human
pose estimation so where's the right
hand where's the left hand
what pose is this person currently doing
which obviously you can imagine has lots
of implications for things like Kinect
sensors and sort of interactive games
but also you know pedestrian tracking
and and loads of other examples of
things where it might be useful to know
what a person is up to and finally we're
using obviously implant science to try
and count objects and localize objects
so where's for disease on this image can
we produce a heat map that shows exactly
where it is where are the ears of wheat
in this image can we count the number of
spikelets to get an estimate of how much
yield this week is producing compared to
this wheat and then we can start to run
experiments on you know these ones are
water-stressed does that does that mean
this one's better this kind of thing so
this is called an encoder decoder
because since sometimes what we're doing
is we were encoding our spatial
information to some kind of features of
what's going on in the scene in general
we remove the spatial resolution in
exchange for learning more about the
scene and then we bring it back in by
finding detail from earlier parts of the
network and bringing them in as well
that's for decoding stage in some
Centris is a little bit like again in
the sense of this is the generator here
and this is a discriminator it's just
that you would switch around but let's
not go not over complicate things
and this one lit up which is maybe pause
and maybe this one lit up because here
was a few lines in a row and this one is
sort of Furby texture or something you
know and we're getting lower and lower
level as we go through